مع بدايه العام الجديد هناك قاعده تتردد
دائما لتتحول من شخص عادي الى شخص ناجح
هذه القاعده تسمى قاعده الساعات الخمس وهي
تعود الى الاضواء مع الظهور معلومات عن
استخدامها من اكبر اثريه العالم وضع مايكل
سيمنس الخبير العالم هذه القاعده المبنيه
على مفهوم البسيط هي انشغال لا يمنعك من
قضاء ما لا يقل عن ساعه يوميا او خمس
ساعات اسبوعيا في التعلم او تدريب الاجزاء
الثلاثه لقاعده الخمس ساعات تكمن في
القراءه والتامل والتجربه
بالقدس مثلا يقول انه تعلم من القراءه
وتاكد دراسات ان التامل يحفز التعلم بينما
تقول شركه جوجل لانها تحسنت لانها تركت
المجال لموظفيها ليجربوا اشياء جديده
على كل حال مزيد عن هذه القاعده مع علاء
يكشف كاتبه انه امضي خمس سنوات في اجراء
مقابلات مع اكثر من 200
مليارا ليعرف سر نجاحهم وتوصل لست عادات
رئيسيه يقول تقرير ان اصحاب الملايين
يتعلمون باستمرار
99% منهم افادوا بانهم استغرقوا بضع دقائق
كل يوم لتعلم كلمات جديده واحد و 60% منهم
مارسوا مهارات جديده لمده لا تقل عن
ساعتين في اليوم رياضه مثلا او الاستماع
يستمعون اكثر مما يتحدثون
ومتوسط النسبه اظهر استماعهم خمس دقائق
مقابل التحدث لدقيقه واحده وقال واحد
وثمانون بالمئه منهم انهم يسمعون دائما
يسعون للاستماع لتعليقات الاخ اصحاب
الملايين يبنون فرقا عظيمه
86% منهم يعملون بمعدل 50 ساعه او اكثر
اسبوعيا لكن الاهم هو العمل مع فريق يعوض
نقاط ضعفهم من وقت وطاقه عقليه او جسديه
وتقول هذه الدراسه ان اصحاب الملايين
يهتمون ايضا بصحتهم ويبتعدون عن السهر
والاهم يقراون المخاطر الماليه ولا يورطون
انفسهم فيها
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينورنا
يسعد صباحك بالسنه الجديده
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا صباح الخيرات بهذه الاجواء
الرائعه الماضيه في المملكه وشكرا انا
نصيحه قبل ما نبدا اي شيء انهم تابعوا
صباح العربيه
هلا ممكن تكون كافيه على انك ممكن تقرا
بالاضافه الى قراءه
صباح العربيه شامله قاعده الساعات الخمس
ات الكتب وتقارير انفسكم
ثقافيه مو لازم تقرا ممكن تسمع وتشوف طيب
اللي بيفهموا منك الانشغال لا يمنع من
التعلم انت مع قاعده ساعات الخمس لانه
تجعلك شخص ناجح طبعا انا اللي يقول لي
مشغول اقول له افتح جوالك على سكرين تايم
وقل لي كم ساعه تقضي على جوالك او على
النت فلكس او على التلفزيون هتلاقي ساعات
كثيره جدا وانا صعدت من احد الاشخاص لمجلس
معهم 11 ساعه في اليوم او 12 ساعه معدل
ثمانيه ساعات خلينا نحسب لو ساعه واحده في
اليوم زي ما اتفضلوا
تعادل في السنه 365 ساعه لو قسمناها على
ساعات الدوام هي 8 ساعات هتمثل لنا 45 يوم
عمل الناس تفكر 45 يوم عمل تساوي شهر ونص
لا 45 يوم عمل لانه عندنا خمسه ايام عمل
في الاسبوع ليس السبعه يعني تقريبا 22 يوم
عمل بالشهر 22 و 22 تسوي 44 يوم
عمل الساعه في اليوم تعادل اكثر من شهرين
تخيل انك
كبيره
واشتغل من الصباح الى المساء على مشروع
الخاص هذا هو نفس ما يعامله تفريخك لساعه
واحده في اليوم كانك جالس شهرين تخيلي
يعني المراس في احد اللقاءات بيقول كنت
ابغى مختصين في مجال الفضاء عشان الصواريخ
وعشان يبقى يسوي الصاروخ يروح ويرجع مره
ثانيه بشكل عامود يقول اسعارهم غاليه جدا
اكثر من قدرتي على ميزانيه الموضوع ايش
سوى راح اقرا كتب
الحديث على هذه القراءه انا دائما بهمني
اوصل للنتيجه النهائيه وبي اسرع وقت ممكن
بقولوا لك قاعده المليارديريه انه اذا
تجاوزت 30 والاربعين وانت لا تقرا فانت
محروم فهل فعلا بالقراءه نستطيع جني المال
بطريقه اسرع واوسع
اعطيك مثال بسيط جدا يعني اذا كان في
مهاره معينه تحتاجيها عشان تقنعي مستثمر
عشان تبداي مشروع خلينا نقول مثلا
الدقيق الان معاني
تحول الى مقدم برنامج في قناه العربيه الى
منتج للبرنامج وتشتريه منه العربيه الى
اداره
ايش المهارات اللي تعلمها كيف عرفت يخرج
من مجرد من يقدم الى يعرف صناعه الانتاج
كل مهاره تتعلميها تخرجك من مكان الى مكان
اعلى معلومه مثلا النظر الى شمس الشروق
تعدل ساعتك الباروديه
عن الكتب عن القراءه اليوم هل يمكن ادراج
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي جزءا من حياتنا
خصوصا مثلا تويتر الغني بالمعلومات
والعواجب الاخبار هل يمكن ضمها هذه
القاعده شكرا على السؤال الجميل المعلومه
مهمه عاجل واخبار الدماء تتصدر الانباء
يعني اغلب الاشياء اللي فيها خطر عليك
اتفرج على شيء انا ما لي فيه في قاعده
اسمها دائره التاثير ودائره
تعرف التقدير هو الشيء اللي اقدر اجلس
ااثر فيه لو سويت شيء يتغير دائره
الاهتمام انا ما عندي
كنت في المقابل اللي بيقول لك اللي هو ما
قرا الا ان عمرك 30 40 راح عليه الاشياء
الكثيره الان في البديل من مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي عندنا ابلكيشن عندنا اليوتيوب
انا انسان سمعي ما اقرا كثير واجلس اسمع
كتاب مثلا قوه عقلك الباطن غير حياتي 180
درجه
كتابتش كتاب مهمات
البنات
اللي ما حصلت له فرصه مهاره القراءه
يعوضها بالاستماع والاشتراك في
الملخصات الحواريه ترا- طالما احتفلنا
جميعا بقدوم العام الجديد واغلبنا يعني
يضع اهداف ويكون النسخه الافضل من السنه
التي مضت من اين نبدا اذا
الله في قاعده روبن شارما في الكتاب
الخامسه صباحا عنده قائمه جميله جدا اسمها
ناينتي ناين ابدئي بالاهداف اللي تمس قيمك
واحلام
اللي بعدها في قاعده يعني 90 يوم 90 دقيقه
خذي ثلاثه اهداف في كل ربع سنه في كل
ثلاثه اشهر اعطى لكل هدف ساعه ونصف ساعه
ونص ساعه ونصف فقط
شوفي انه عندك امكانيه تاخذني هدف الصباح
هدف الظهر
وانت مرتاحه
وهتكتشف انك انجزتي فيها انجاز ما تتخيلي
مشكلتنا نبغى نحقق كل الاهداف من الشهر
الاول فلا نحقق ولا شيء طوال العام
بالكامل وترد اتمنى انه بهذا العام الجديد
بما انك حتكون ضيف يعني معتمد وكثير راح
تطلع معنا شويه تحسن الاضاءه بالكاميرا بس
هذه امنيتي
ان شاء الله اكبر